so we have two examples here where we're
given the magnitude of a vector and its
direction and the direction is by giving
us an angle that it forms with the
positive x-axis what we need to do is go
from having this magnitude in this angle
this direction to figuring out what the
x and y components of this vector
actually are so like always pause this
video and see if you can if you can work
through this on your own
alright now let's let's work through
this together and it's really just going
to involve a little bit of trigonometry
so we want to break this vector down
into its horizontal and it's a vertical
components or its X&Y components so I
could draw it's I could draw its
horizontal component just like this so
it's going to look something like let me
draw it I can do a better job than that
so it's going to look something like
that that's its horizontal component or
its X component and then its vertical
component is going to look something
like this
it's going to look like that that's its
vertical component and notice if you add
the horizontal component and the
vertical component you are going to get
your original vector now I've just
constructed a right triangle and in this
type of a right triangle I could just
use actually some of my most basic trig
definitions or the simplest form which
is the sohcahtoa definition of the trig
functions I might want to break into the
unit circle definition later on but if I
want to figure out the magnitude of this
base right over here we see that that is
adjacent to this 50 degree angle it's
not the hypotenuse it's the other side
that forms the angle and so what trig
function deals with adjacent and
hypotenuse well we could just put a
little reminder here so Toa well cosine
deals with adjacent over hypotenuse so
we could say that if I call if I call
this X the length of our X component we
could say that the cosine the cosine of
50 degrees of our angle is going to be
equal to the length of the adjacent side
X over the length of our hypotenuse
which is the magnitude of the vector
over 4 and so if I want to solve for x
just multiply both sides by four so I
could get four times cosine of 50
degrees four times cosine of 50 degrees
is equal is equal to X now what about
the Y component so the Y component what
is that going to be well what that that
side the length of that side is opposite
to the angle the 50 degree angle so what
trig functional deals with opposite and
hypotenuse
well that is signed so we know that the
sine of 50 degrees is going to be equal
to Y over the length of the hypotenuse Y
over 4 and so we can multiply both sides
by 4 and we get we get 4 times sine of
50 degrees sine of 50 degrees is equal
to Y and so if I don't have a calculator
I could just write that this I could
this vector I could write as if I write
it in the component form its X component
is 4 cosine of 50 degrees and its Y
component is 4 sine of 50 degrees and
you might notice something interesting
here and I have cosine full of the angle
the angle we form with the positive
x-axis I have that for the x coordinate
I have signed on the y coordinate and
then I just multiply it by the magnitude
of the vector can I always do that well
it turns out you can and this comes out
of the unit circle definition of the
trig functions the unit circle
definition of trig functions cosine if
you have a unit circle so the unit
circle looks like this a unit circle has
a radius of 1 cosine is the x-coordinate
of where you intersect the unit circle
and sine is the y-coordinate or if you
had a vector of magnitude 1 it would be
cosine of that angle would be the X
component for if we had a unit vector
there in that direction and then sine
would be the Y component well we don't
have a unit vector our vector has a
magnitude of 4 it's 4 times bigger than
a unit vector so each of the components
are going to be 4 times bigger
so that's why we multiply the X the
cosine of 50 by 4 to get the X component
and we take the sine of 50 and we
multiply it by 4 to get the y component
that's going to come in handy when we
think about this one over here but we
could get our calculator out and
approximate what these are going to be
so let me get it out where's my
calculator all right there we go
so 50 I'm in degree mode got to make
sure so 50 degrees I'm going to take the
cosine and I'm going to multiply it
times 4 so times 4 is equal to 2
approximately two point five seven so
this is approximately equal to two point
five seven is our X component and then
our Y component our Y component
if I take 50 degrees and if I take the
sine of it and then multiply it by 4 I
get approximately three point zero six
three point zero six and we see that
over here this X this X component looks
like it's a little more than two and a
half and this Y component looks like
it's slightly more than three so it all
worked out even though this is kind of a
sloppy hand-drawn graph all right now
let's tackle this one and this is
interesting because this the terminal
point when we draw it in standard form
is in the second quadrant so what would
be the x and y components here you can
immediately tell because we're in the
second quadrant our X component is going
to be negative and our Y component is
going to be is going to be positive well
we could just resort exactly to what we
did just there we could say well this
vector this vector is going to be the
magnitude its X component is going to be
its magnitude times the cosine of the
angle that it forms with the positive x
axis cosine of 135 degrees and its Y
component is going to be the magnitude
times the sine of the angle that it
forms with the positive x axis and we'd
be done and we can evaluate each of
these things so we could get let me get
my calculator out again so if we take
135 degrees and if I take the cosine of
that cosine of that and then multiply it
by 10 times 10 I get approximately
negative seven point zero seven so
that's approximately
negative seven point zero seven and then
if I take the sign and we're going to
see something very similar so 135
degrees I take the sign of it I get
positive point 707 and so let me
multiply that times the magnitude times
10 is equal to seven point zero seven so
seven point oh seven and we see that
over here this is roughly looks like
it's a little more than seven looks like
it's a little bit more than seven in
that direction and we'd be done and you
might say well once again how did this
work well if I had a unit circle if I
had a unit circle right over here and if
I had a unit vector so its terminal
point would sit on the unit circle that
went in the exact same direction that
still formed 135 degrees this point this
point right over here it would have the
coordinates cosine of 135 degrees sine
of 135 degrees let me make it a little
bit more visible at this point right
over here cosine 135 sine of 135 would
be its coordinates or for this unit
vector right over here to going in that
direction its X component would be
cosine of 135 and it's Y component would
be sine of 135 well the vector that we
care about has 10 times the magnitude of
a unit vector in that direction so it's
X component is going to have ten times
the magnitude and so is its Y component
and you could even resort to your
sohcahtoa definitions to figure this out
we could construct a right triangle if
we like we could say we could say here
is we could say here is my X component
that is my X component it's going to be
something like that and then there and
then my Y component is going to look
something like I'm drawing a little bit
imprecise but I could draw that let me
draw it a little bit better my Y
components going to look something like
that
right triangle and so if I want this
magnitude the magnitude of this bottom
side I would say well look I know I know
if this is if this is 135 degrees this
angle right over here supplementary to
that so it's a 45 degree angle and so
what trig function deals with adjacent
and hypotenuse will cosign
so I could say cosine of 45 degrees is
equal to the length of this so let me
just call the length of that I don't
know let me just call it X so the length
of it x over the hypotenuse over 10
multiplied both sides by 10 you get 10
times cosine of 45 degrees is equal to X
and cosine of 45 degrees is square root
of 2 over 2
so this is going to be 5 square roots of
2 is equal to X and you might say wait
wait I thought this is supposed to be
negative well the way we just solved it
right now with our right triangle we
just figured out the magnitude of the
side and then we would just have to
reason okay but we're not going we're
not going 5 square roots of 2 to the
right we're going 5 square roots of 2 to
the left so the magnitude in the X
direction or not the magnitude our X
component I should say is going to be
negative 5 square roots of 2 and you can
do the exact same reasoning to say well
10 cosine of 4 it's 10 sine of 45
degrees is going to give us the
magnitude of the of the Y component and
that's actually going to be our Y
component so same exact thing this is
going to be 10 sine of 45 degrees which
is 5 square roots of 2 and if we took
our calculator out they would evaluate
to approximately these things right over
there